what is your take on this whole God view
thing I mean uber says look only certain
employees can see this data it's only
for legitimate business or legitimate
business purposes so we as we discovered
24 hours before they included legitimate
business purposes included going through
my garbage and having me followed so I
don't have a lot of confidence in what
uber considers it a legitimate business
purpose let me push back just a little
bit did they actually go through the
plan to go through your garbage of our
kids was it just merely suggested at the
dinner um look I as far as I know they
haven't but I don't know okay I have no
way of knowing and do you think this is
something that's pervasive of ubers
company cultures this is a couple of
employees who are out of line you know
what I think it's somewhere between the
two I used to take uber for a long time
and for a long time you know we've
started raising questions about this
company's ethics and morality since 2012
which is one of the reasons I was the
one targeted and I still used the
ride-sharing app up until recently
because I really liked a lot of the
drivers I interacted with and I thought
even though Travis kalanick is obviously
morally corrupted and has a board who
will not stand up to him I thought in
spite of that they were doing some good
in the world and I did really like some
of the things that they were doing give
me a saw they're employing 50,000 new
people right right but but at this point
you know we have all covered startups
long enough to know that culture comes
from the top and the senior executive
sets a tone and what we see over and
over again when uber gets in these PR
messes they'd never fire anyone
responsible now what message does that
send if you're at the company I get
rewarded for taking more risks that
frequently involve putting women's lives
in danger this I mean look look you have
young children we all have young
children what does a three-year-old do
when they are expressing bad behavior
that doesn't get checked
doesn't get checked doesn't get checked
it escalates what's happening now is the
biggest
Ebor scandal because none of the other
stuff has ever been checked but that's a
culture so you have goober investment
and and people who haven't invested in
uber who wish that they did mm-hmm Colin
Travis kalanick you know one of the best
tech CEOs ever comparing him to Amazon
CEO Jeff Bezos I mean you know I've
talked to Travis kalanick he's as
vericsson saying he worked he's very
passionate
is is is there something wrong with his
strategy with I think there is always
something wrong with no one questioning
a founder and what's happening right now
is the board and investors are terrified
of him this is the first time in Silicon
Valley my time covering Silicon Valley I
have ever thought a company would be
served by going public immediately
because I think public market investors
would not let one person have this much
power and control unchecked but
unfortunately in Silicon Valley
this company has gotten so valuable so
quickly and the big mega multi-billion
dollar home runs are so rare that people
simply are terrified they will not do
anything this company arty has hit a
homerun I mean they're winning the
market so you wonder why why do they
have to resort to what some people have
called I don't know it's I know the
plans of what was gonna be done to my
family frankly a lot of the investors
have young children I think some of
these people see Travis's guy they don't
want to cross when you just happen with
Hewlett Packard something similar they
say they were concerned about the board
level or the CEO was concerned about a
leak
one of the board members talking to
somebody in the press and so they hire
private investigators to illegally
pretexts phone calls get the phone
records of all these reporters a couple
of whom now work at Bloomberg but didn't
at the time and go through their garbage
as well hired private investigators to
legally go through the garbage but there
was a criminal investigation do you
think there needs to be an investigation
based on what's happened to you if
anything's have to do at all I don't
think we're at the point of a criminal
investigation yet and I think that is
solely because of Ben Smith's journalism
and Ben Smith's conscience I am
preparing for the fact that no one has
been fired no actions have been taken
and as soon as this dies down they will
come at me in this or a worse way I'm
convinced of it when it comes to data
uber is certainly not the first company
to struggle with how do they handle
customer data from Facebook to Google
how should they handle the data that
they're getting very valuable well you
know I think that we see I mean again
the the examples of misogyny in this
company are astounding I mean there's
the whole glory rides thing where they
were tracking by looking at the data
patterns who was having one-night stands
and
you know fist bumping and high-fiving
people virtually over this I mean this
is a company that clearly is not just
looking at customer data in order to
route cars more effectively and when you
talk about the sort of data they have on
you they're making assumptions of are
you sleeping with someone based on your
patterns
it's really quite scary well in terms of
the privacy I mean you know you can
imagine our young company would struggle
with these things is there a point at
which we've seen this with other
companies where privacy matters you know
because when a different era now where
we're mobile phones and people are
getting types of data that they never
could before does there need to be a
different kind of privacy for all the
companies are in this arena look I mean
this story is fascinating because it is
a litmus test for Silicon Valley
investors and do they have a conscience
over money it is a litmus test for
journalists and will they stand up and
say you cannot dismantle us and does the
first minute matter and is also a litmus
test for the public you know in the past
people have voted with their feet when
it comes to Facebook or Google when it
comes to privacy but uber is very
different because it's the real world
you know you're getting in people's cars
is that finally scary enough that it
changes consumer behavior and also uber
unlike Facebook there are are other
alternatives I mean at the end of the
day I don't know about you guys but when
I take any of the ride-sharing services
in San Francisco they have two to three
phones on the dash because they're
driving all of these services well you
know I should point out like as
frightening as this is and I've been
through this myself in different ways
from investors not from companies but
you know there are journalists out there
in jails and our inner in Iraq you're in
Iran there are journalists covering Isis
who are scared to death and they face
actual death threats every day it's on a
different level which I think we should
acknowledge that at very least I think
that's true but frankly if you're a
mother and they're threats made against
your children that's do you think hard
to imagine it really was made against
your based on what I've heard and based
of what I know of this company I'm
convinced about that frightening stuff
yeah
it's easy to be a tough journalist and
write the stories and push them out and
then and but not sort of get that
involvement but I think you know at
Ashton Kutcher's comment I mean Ashton
Kutcher was saying on Twitter this
morning Emily sent it out this morning
to us and saying why shouldn't
journalists be held to the same standard
I think that it's not really about that
I mean what we do we should absolutely
be held a stand but also what is this
going through I mean this is how they're
trying to reframe it she knew his
treasure
very careful for us to actually hold
them to what they said and not allow
them to twist what they said Emile
Michel said give me a taste of my own
medicine
well I've never gone through these
people's trash I've never followed their
kids I've never hired on a
million-dollar budget a team of
opposition researchers to go at their
family and despise it clear they didn't
we were it's not clear that they
actually know but the plan was to give
me a taste of my own medicine along
those lines and and uber uber spokes
which has said we do not do this we do
not invest retirement not our power why
haven't they fired him if his views
didn't first of all if the if what he
said doesn't represent his views whose
views do they represent they came out of
his mouth he's not denying that and if
it if they are horrified if they found
these comments inhuman why haven't they
fired him no this is just one person who
said this right is it do you think this
do do you know this goes beyond that I
mean speaking of Travis for example um I
I definitely know secondhand accounts
I mean I've not had anyone say it to me
what do you think Travis was at that's
this dinner Travis was a was at this
dinner but my question is what was heard
who heard what Emil Michael sat aside
from Ben Smith and look I was we don't
know the bottom line is we don't I
wasn't there I know Travis very well I
think what concerns me is I also know
several the board members and investors
very well and I emailed them as soon as
Ben Smith story come out and I'll name
some of them Sherman piss revoir Rob
Hayes from first round bill Gurley from
benchmark and I said I need to know do
you support this company using a million
dollars of your money to smear me not a
single one has even called me back or
emailed fascinated it's amazing stuff
it's amazing also the lessons from
Hewlett Packard you know cuz a lot of
people were still around wasn't that
long ago was ten years ago yeah and is
amazing that those lessons weren't
learned
why that's bad it's also interesting to
me that that these business executives
don't seem to appreciate the role of
journalism and why journey makes their
businesses better makes their society
better helps their helps their companies
start to get some attention when they
come up with these great ideas would you
know yeah look I thought there might be
the idea of OpenTable missile agretti
here's a question you know Travis said
executives and people anyone can can and
should be given the opportunity to learn
from their mistakes should any of this
be forgiven no I mean I mean no you have
to earn forgiveness
you've to earn forgiveness and the
apology I mean have you seen there's no
actions
there's no act no one has been fired and
today you see again political strategy
101 a celebrity investor who has a
higher profile than anyone coming out
calling me a shady journalist the same
thing they do when women drivers say
they've been attacked in their cars
attack my character they are doing the
same playbook they outline I thought I
was telling that in Travis's Twitter
sort of blast that he used the word
folks which is a word that President
Obama seems to use uncomfortably as well
when he's trying to seem like regular
people
and a lot of people noted that he thinks
he apologized to me at the end do you
think any of this is going to matter to
customers does this affect their bid I
hope so because I think that's frankly
the only hope cuz we've seen investors
won't act all right you know I do want
to add that we did reach out to Eber and
asked them if they wanted to have a
voice in this conversation and they did
give us those statements